questo punto di quelle meccanismi
globali che si occupa di agricoltura ai
sistemi alimentari per la nutrizione gli
hanno pubblicato i gente molto
importante
non vado in dettagli finanziato bill e
melinda gates come no le inglesi
eccetera e il 23 settembre scorso hanno
lasciato un rapporto di prospettiva
sulle sistemi alimentari e la dieta
alimentare quello che diceva questo
rapporto è che adesso abbiamo una crisi
nutrizionale che sta peggiorando
c'è una riduzione della fame e della
denutrizione non in somalia non è nient
però in generale se sa che adesso la fa
mi colpisce una persona su dieci è un
bambino su quattro è cronicamente
malnutrito un problema che il rid o
ridotto e il problema molto grave adesso
e che sta aumentando la prevalenza
dell'obesità e delle malattie croniche
che sono legate a un alimenta la
limentazione cancri diabete e malattie
cardiovascolari
siamo messi male e anche abbiamo più dei
2 miliardi di persone che presentano
carenze in micro nutriente come ferro
zinco vitamina a
questo vuol dire che adesso abbiamo una
persona su tre nel mondo su tre nel
mondo che malnutrita tutte le forme di
malnutrizione e saranno una persona su
due si continuiamo così e nel 2030
adesso la malnutrizione e dunque i
principali fattori di rischio delle
malattie nel mondo e le sistemi
alimentare dunque sono disfunzionale
se sto dicendo adesso è la prima volta
che lo sentivo ufficialmente dei
colleghi perché perché non
le giudichiamo adesso sul fatto che non
forniscono un alimentazione equilibrata
fino adesso si guardava si erano
economicamente viabile eccetera eccetera
io adesso dico va bene questi problemi
system e non funzionano perché sono
insensati sulla quantità della
produzione non sulla qualità degli
alimenti che se vanno produrre non
aiutano i consumatori a fare scelte
alimentari sane e accessibile
vediamo la pubblicità quello che ci
incoraggiano a consumare e siamo
ovviamente in un mondo in cambiamento
dobbiamo adattarsi a questi cambiamenti
abbiamo una pressione demografica
abbiamo parlato del centro italia che si
svuotava però ci sono altre zone
ovviamente dove arrivano tanti migranti
abbiamo il cambiamento climatico è una
pressione accentuata sulle risorse
naturali del tipo di agricoltura
urbanizzazione eccetera che abbiamo
messo in moto
dunque è la conclusione di questo
rapporto era anche la nutrizione è una
priorità mondiale è il vantaggio è che
adesso siamo in un contesto
internazionale piuttosto positivo perchè
se ha detto che dove hanno adottato e
nel 2015 degli obiettivi di sviluppo
sostenibile per l'agenda fine 2030 e c'è
un decennio delle nazioni unite per
l'action per l'azione sulla nutrizione
del 2016 a 2.025 mirate tutte quelle
sono grandi circhi e vero però aiuta
anche a orientale un certo numero di
sforzi politiche e strategie
la cosa più importante è che sì parliamo
di fa ricerca sul cibo l'agricoltura e
la nutrizione
dobbiamo ricentrare questa ricerca
sull'accesso a una dieta alimentare sana
le due
obiettivi della gente 2003 sono e
l'oggettivo due più pertinente sono
quello di eliminare la fame assicurare
la sicurezza alimentare quello già c'era
prima però migliorare la nutrizione e
promuovere l'agricoltura sostenibile è
la prima volta che se parla in quelle
grandi dichiarazioni dell'agricoltura
sostenibile e l'obiettivo 11 che de
creare città sostenibile insediamenti
umani che siano inclusivi sicuri i
solidi vedremo perché dopo il decennio
sulla nutrizione basicamente riprende le
dieci impegni della seconda conferenza
internazionale sulla nutrizione di
novembre 2014
e c'è stato l'inizio di dicembre a roma
un simposio internazionale su sistemi
alimentari sostenibili per
un'alimentazione sana e una nutrizione
migliorata
capisco che per gente che non sa in
quella tematica samb è però quello che
si sta parlando adesso è che dobbiamo ri
orientare gli sistemi alimentari per
un'alimentazione sostenibile che sarebbe
un'alimentazione sostenibile
ovviamente e un'alimentazione che il
nutrizionalmente adeguata e sana però
anche deve essere culturalmente
accettabile accessibile finanziarmente
ed equa e deve avere un impatto
ambientale limitato rispettare la
biodiversità ed ecosistemi per avere
queste cambio dei consumatori e le
sindaci saranno al cuore della
transazione è il cambiamento non
possiamo sognare che il cambiamento
partirà dell'offerta legale agente che
gestisce la produzione adesso le grande
quello che già hanno il potere stato
contentissimo come vanno le cose
dunque loro cambieranno un po di cose
per essere più decenti però non cambierà
e il cambio cambierà della domanda
la metà dei consumatori urbani
dei consumatori del pianeta sono urbani
ormai più della metà le popolazioni
vivacità dei consumatori quelli di voi
che conoscete carlo petrini slow food
eccetera
sa che le consumatori sono co produttori
sì noi possiamo le nostri soldi per
comprare cibo noi giustifichiamo il
sistema di produzione che ha prodotto
questo sito e che lo ha portato al
commercio dove andiamo
se vogliamo avere una delle politiche
pubbliche sostenibile sarà importante
partire di un'alimentazione sostenibile
dunque è il cambio partirà della domanda
e al cambio partirà del livello locale
sono le municipi e le governi locali che
sono in prima linea
ovviamente devono essere collegati con i
livelli regionali nazionali e globali e
devono essere collegati fra di loro
soprattutto nei territori che hanno
circostanze agroecologiche i storiche
economiche simile diciamo in europa due
territori dei due parti della stessa
frontiera e molto e in generale a
preoccupazione comuni soluzioni comuni
che sono diverse delle soluzioni
nazionali dunque dobbiamo cominciare a
pensare non soltanto a livello europeo e
livello nazionale molto di meno ea
livello locale può permettere fare ponti
catena alimentare
tanta gente dice steve bolze sebo
successo dagli utenti
le catene alimentari prendi un elemento
di una dieta e lo voglia guardare della
produzione fine al piatto tu stai
perdendo la visione del sistema la gente
non è che mangia un prodotto alimentario
se consuma una dieta le sistemi
alimentari sono compresi
dire complicati però sono complessi e
sono strettamente collegati con la
cultura non si mangia solo non si mangia
nutrienti sì io vi invito a cena
vedo che gli posso fa che posso
preparare che vi faccia piacere iref
lettera tanto le vostre aspettative come
quello che penso a poter offrire dunque
non guarderò le indumenti per ottenere
diete sostenibili e dovremo articolare
con un sistema globale con tutto quello
di globalizzazione che si sta spingendo
commercio internazionale eccetera
eccetera e il sistema locale e dunque
vedere come le catene alimentari possono
contribuire a questi sistemi
questo vuol dire che dovremo rivedere le
system strumenti giuridici tutti voi che
lavorate in quello dell'agricoltura
sappiamo benissimo che tutte le norme
sul latte eccetera
stanno distruggendo tutta una parte
dell'agricoltura
dunque dobbiamo rivedere questi in
strumenti e dobbiamo reeves aree nei
sistemi di misurazione e valutazione
dobbiamo completamente cambiare ricerca
non possiamo continuare con del tipo di
ricerca che abbiamo
c'è un panel che ha scritto tutto un
lavoro su quello dieci principi olistico
integrare le relazioni di potere perché
sono loro che decidono tutte trances i
binari coinvolgimento tutti gli attori
eccetera eccetera
vorrei terminare per parlare vede una
esperienza di milano di nuovo è che il
milan
parallelamente aveva cominciato al
comune in limine anno e il processo è
probabilmente quello secondo quelli di
noi che erano coinvolti pensiamo che sia
una cosa molto importante dei sindaci
hanno cominciato a pensare come facciamo
per avere politiche alimentari e
sostenibile sistemi alimentari
sostenibili come facciamo dobbiamo
guardare gli aspetti di governance come
farei lavora nelle municipi con
accademia con del settore privato con la
società
civile non vi dico che dobbiamo
promuovere jet e sostenibile e una buona
nutrizione della nostra popolazione sino
non possiamo pagare i costi a termine
salute dobbiamo guardare tutte le
aspetti di equità sociale economica le
aspetti di approvvigionamento e
distribuzione alimentare dunque tutte le
aspetti il mercato centrale di firenze
abbiamo sentito a ieri le catene corte
le gruppi di acquisto solidale eccetera
la produzione che sarebbe tutta
l'aspetto agroecologia agricoltura
biologica eccetera e la gestione delle
risorse naturali e prevenire e gestire
lo spreco alimentare dunque entra
tantissimo cost tantissime cose in una
politica alimentare queste parto essa è
un iniziativa dei sindaci non entrato
nazione unita non entrato tecnici e una
cosa che hanno deciso a livello di
sindaci è stato firmato di 137 città
delle quali 10 8 italiane nel quale
bologna firenze in roma con quello è
stato illustrato di 50 buone pratiche
del modo che li sindaci vedono che si
può fare concretamente sono buone
pratiche delle città che stanno in
quella rete era stato consegnato a la
foto prima era ban ki moon che era
segretario delle nazioni unite a quel
momento il 2015
c'è un summit dei sindaci tutti gli anni
l'anno scorso era in roma queste hanno
sera a valencia
non penso che grossetto abbia firmato un
peccato la cosa interessante è che c'è
una rete ed eccita livello
internazionale io no words program che
permette alle città di so mettere le
buone pratiche per cambiare buone
pratiche piccole città tipo nuova york
shanghai san paolo però anche sacile
insomma stiamo parlando di qualsiasi
città interessata può benissimo usare
queste patto alimentari o vedere che
quello che già stanno facendo come lo
potranno fare meglio e più articolato le
relazioni fra territorio ecc e
territorio il cibo sono essenziali e io
ho provato a riprendere cose consentito
ieri e le riunioni referti primo il
territorio dove le idee hanno le gambe
questo mi è piaciuto tanto come
espansione perché è vero che a livello
di territorio e dove tu trovi la
problematica ambientale la problematica
sociali e la problematica economica e li
puoi vedere come fare compromessi come
andare a paci come imparare assieme per
avere queste approccio collettivo del
quale abbiamo parlato a livello nazione
era assolutamente impossibile
l'innovazione verso la tradizione come
diceva fernando tizi questa mattina si
deve andare un passo indietro e credo
che molto molto importante
documentare quello che se sapeva e
quello che si sta facendo adesso per
avere questa informazione è quello vuol
dire che dovremmo avere squadre
interdisciplinari con gente del posto
con sociologi economisti cod ricercatori
biomedici con e cioè e lavorare assieme
dire quello una realtà la devi amo
capire meglio de modo sistemico
dobbiamo renderci conto che tutti di noi
possiamo aiutare contribuire qualcosa
per la soluzione non è nostra lazio
lesione sera comune e il cibo è un tema
di convergenza tutti parliamo al cibo
tutti i giorni perché non se ne parla di
più quando si parla di politiche di
sviluppo e un tema che può creare
coinvolgimento interdisciplinari
interistituzionale
inter general azioni intergenerazionale
e molto importante perché permette può
proteggere e rinforzare il capitale
sociale
dunque è il cibo deve essere visto come
un bene collettivo e dobbiamo adottare
un sistema tra vita la responsabile
responsabilità cittadina è essenziale
perché sì noi non copriamo questo cibo
locale eccetera eccetera non si andrà
avanti comunque e sarà molto importante
cambiare tutti i metodi di finanziamento
fino adesso l'euro servono però no come
stanno facendo il no ognuno per conto
suo
grazie
[Applauso]